SCP-682 Vs SCP-117.
The Hard to Destroy Reptile Vs The Perfect
Multi-Tool.
But can this ultra-convenient and somewhat
vampiric gadget finally MacGuyver this nasty
lizard out of existence?
The Foundation started with a sample test,
using tissue extracted from 682’s back and
a D-Class in charge of holding the multitool.
The test looked promising.
117 produced a number of pneumatic hammers
and pounded the 682 tissue sample into a fine
slurry, then disintegrated this slurry into
nothingness with particle beam weaponry - leaving
the D-Class it was being handled by, with
an almost deadly mineral deficiency.
However, as you can probably guess, the test
against the whole 682 lizard wasn’t so successful.
Rather than attacking 682, 117 produced a
device that teleported itself and the D-Class
using it away, killing the D-Class in the
process.
Test failed.